you uh of course were a
big break you were the original cast
book of mormon
and uh this one of the biggest hits one
of the biggest hit musicals in memory
everybody every celebrity in the world
came to see that show what was it like
for you
you're in this show it becomes massive
you're peeking out through the curtain
before the show and who are you seeing i
mean i saw everybody from john bon jovi
to oprah winfrey
um to gilbert godfreed right that was
you know uh all in the same night
actually yeah but my favorite was coming
out sitting together in the same seat
all sitting together in one seat gilbert
on top of bon jovi and i remember uh i
remember one night coming out and seeing
this beautiful giraffe like sitting in
the audience and it was you you were so
tall and handsome you called me a
giraffe a beautiful draft that's why you
said tonight i'm an orangutang and a
giraffe
if an orangutan giraffe had a baby you
know you have this incredible
presence and and you were hovering over
the audience you could tell that i was
in the audience you're the only one who
looks like conan o'brien and so i sat
there
and i remember looking at you and being
like i want to do a really good job i
don't remember seeing you but i remember
seeing you i was there but your
gd understudy was there then oh man yeah
i missed the gad experience so i'll do
the entire thing for you right now if
you want me hold on folks
so i'm sitting there and i see you and i
think i overcompensated that night like
i think i was like pitching on a lot of
stuff because i really wanted to impress
you well that's nice of you to say i
mean you were fantastic thank you you
blew me away and it was hard for me
because i'm so giraffe-like yeah you
were drafted
that i had to sit still was very hard
the tongue
everyone else at intermission goes and
gets candy i just eat the leaves from
tall trees
but uh one of the coolest experiences
was bruce springsteen comes
we actually have uh yeah we got a
picture bruce springsteen came to the
show
and took a photo with you backstage
because you can tell how delighted you
are yes uh i was
yeah um and uh yeah he comes backstage
and he looks at me and he goes man you
you got a sick voice that's like the
constipated hungry impression of bruce
springsteen
something like you got a sick voice and
at first i was really excited about it
i'm like oh my god bruce springsteen
just told me i had a sick voice but then
i realized i actually had laryngitis
that week and i think he was commenting
on the fact that my voice did not sound
very good and i felt really bad about
myself i don't think that's what he
meant no i do i do conan i do
uh now i would say in that show i
thought your dance moves really stood
out you had some very unique dancing i i
did it it's called you thrust and it's
just basically like this kind of thing
and what you do what are you doing doing
that what you do it's just this you can
do this on tbs can't you so what you do
is this and and can't wait for 3d
television
so you do that and it just distracts the
eye if they see like a fat man thrusting
it distracts him from the fact that i
can't actually dance
and so a lot of people are just like oh
wow that's really distracting well
everybody else is doing like acrobatics
right so interesting it blew your mind